hey David what is the best way to take
advantage of the corona virus quarantine
in terms of personal development and how
to use free time so I dealt with this a
little bit on the Monday bonus show I've
been trying to get back to number one
first of all making sure that I don't
get out of you know exercise routines
and on nice days I can run outside and
bike I'm working out inside of my place
and trying to keep that even without the
gym as a place that I normally would
regularly go to I think that's important
I've been reading a lot and trying to
get through a lot of books that normally
would take me longer to read I have more
time on weekends I'm just sitting at
home so I'm just reading books I pulled
out my painting supplies again as many
of you remember from the New York City
days of the show I used to do a little
very very bad amateur painting I'm back
doing that a little bit more I'm trying
to do projects around the house I've
been watching a lot of courses on
YouTube great philosophy course of a
sort of a refresher on mechanical
physics which brought me back to my high
school days anything that you believe
here's the way I would sort of think
about it consider this almost like a
hibernation period where instead of
hibernating to reduce food consumption
the way that Bears would do during the
winter your heart hibernating and trying
to improve yourself so that when we come
out of this thing someday we don't know
exactly when you will come out a better
more prepared person for getting back to
normal life and you know existing more
vitally in society and you know all of
that so it listen we're all dealing with
the same thing that's the sort of
best-case scenario that I can imagine
and that's what I'm trying to do I will
admit I have been doing a little bit of
video gaming former producer Lewis
recommended some game to me I forget
that it's some puzzle game that was on
it was available on Steam that he's been
playing I forget the name of it but it's
really really good I've been playing
that a little bit I've been playing
probably more online chess that I
normally do
but I think it's important to mix things
I've been taking scheduled breaks from
the coronavirus news as I did last
Friday Saturday and most of Sunday so I
think it's about balance hanging out
digitally and reconnecting with friends
is something that I've been doing and
it's everybody is experiencing this this
feeling to some degree unless you're not
doing anything I know that in some
states people are still partying on
beaches and going to concerts and that
sort of thing but for those of us who
are taking this seriously I get it I'm
here with you we're doing a lot of live
streams to try to give people
opportunities to you know be in touch
with us and participate but those are
some of my things try to come out of
this a more informed more literate
healthier person if possible and of
course meanwhile trying to avoid the
virus itself we've got a fantastic bonus
show for you today get access instantly
by becoming a member or a patron at join
pakman.com or patreon.com slash david
pakman show